[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
well happy new year to you here's to a
new and improved new year certainly
uh the sounds of a few fireworks there
obviously uh nothing official although
the commemorations
to begin this year are decidedly less
celebratey there is a sense perhaps of
hopeful optimism
that at the very least 2020 is over
we have correspondents out on the
streets tonight alex rossi is in central
london
james matthews is in edinburgh sally
lockwood is in
new york and david blevins is in belfast
to alex first of all i could hear some
people out on the streets maybe some
fireworks in the background
and a happy new year to you happy new
year to our viewers
yes from westminster bridge there was
some celebration it was pretty muted
there are a few
hundred people perhaps more out some
unexpected and impromptu fireworks
you would definitely right you could
hear them through your earpiece
anna the police here are trying to hurt
people away really because
the government's advice uh the
government's direction all of this
has been to stay at home the virus is
still
running rampant but people have come out
probably
because there isn't much else to do some
people have come out they say to stretch
their legs
to get out of their their flats and
homes they just wanted to go for a walk
others have come here because they
couldn't resist the
pull of the sound of hearing big ben
bong for the sound of midnight and
ringing in
the new year but it feels really
very different to what it should do but
that's not surprising this is one of the
strangest years
we've had in living room memory remember
this time last year hundreds of
thousands of people would be here on
westminster bridge
lining the embankment down there that
way
as well and of course the focus over
there anna on
the london eye where you would have seen
that spectacular
uh firework uh display that we
traditionally see at this time of year
that of course has been cancelled
most of the celebrations going online
virtual celebrations because people are
staying indoors but
as you can see some people have come out
defying the advice of the government
to try and see in the new year and james
matthews in edinburgh now those
huge hogmanay celebrations on the hold
for now there too
yeah they are and it's a big blue anna
for this city you know economically it's
worth something like
30 million pounds the big party that
takes place here in the home of hogmanay
it extends over the festive period
center of course around the castle which
is blue
lit blue there was a single firework
come the midnighter i'm not
entirely sure what that was about but it
was appreciated by
a very small crowd here take a look uh
just behind the camera
some people gathered i suspect some
people thought they might be seeing some
kind of firework display tonight but
um that hasn't happened i'll speak to
some of the people hello there happy new
year
um how are you happy new year
uh yeah we're live on sky news cheers
tell me did you come here expecting a
big party
what's going on here it's oh
amazing yeah what do you think it's
quiet it's is it strange
it's quite different than usual usually
it's very very busy
yeah yeah what do you prefer this i mean
this year we all much closer than before
something that's better
what happened to you thank you for that
and there's a guy over here from morocco
anna let's have a
chat with him i think he's brought his
uh streaming live himself
mate hello
are you going to do your dance for us
yeah definitely okay go for it
[Music]
tell me where are you from morocco
morocco um basically from
north africa and what do you think of of
this
it's okay it's okay to be honest
we want more like music and all i do
music here
i survive from music so at the moment
there is
it's not whatever i wanted you know it's
quiet is it strange very quiet very very
quiet a strange feeling
but i'm grateful anyway i'm still alive
i'm very much i'm i'm i'm 31 years old
now i'm 31.
it's great it's strange and we're all
alive thank you for that happy new year
there you go from uh from a quiet fairly
strange edinburgh
certainly on typical back to you